[Music]
distinguished uh members of the media
now we will hear the statements of prime
minister kovesi and the president of the
European
commission I invite the Prime Minister
distinguished president of the European
commissiona distinguished members of the
government distinguished members from
the European commission distinguished
representatives of the press
distinguished citizens
today I was honored to host the
president of the European commission Ura
fan and I must say that she's one of the
greatest friends of North Macedonia dear
Ursula welcome to Scopia I highly
appreciate that um your four days visit
to the region starts
here whenever president fan comes here
she comes with concrete steps and plans
for approximation of the country and the
region to the European Union
she was here last year in October when
we signed the frontex agreement the
first one between the European
Commission on North Macedonia in
Macedonian language which is already in
practice today she comes with concrete
growth plan which for the Western
Balkans which we discussed on our
meeting and which and which will enable
the citizens and the companies to feel
the same benefits that the citizens of
the European Union have even before full
membership this plan was something that
we asked from the European Union and
hence I want to thank the president for
her commitment and the commitment of her
team who worked on the preparation of
this growth
plan I would like to personally thank
you for listening our needs and the
needs of the region and of course I
highly appreciate your personal
leadership shown on this issue this plan
will give a new strong stimulus to the
euro integration
process we know that this is a process
that consists of two paths one political
and the other one an economic one we
must not forget that the European Union
lies on both political and economic
cooperation between the member
states after we complete the process
which depends on the European Union but
most of all on us on the western Balan
countries will double the scope of
economy in the region and in the country
by increased economic
cooperation only by setting and
reinforcing the single regional market
Market our economies are expected to
grow about
10% and by opening the door to the
single European market as foreseen in
this plan the opportunities are
enormous I would like to State a brief
part of the benefits that is opportunity
for opening the market of the European
Union for Macedonian
products thus eliminating the
barriers and in the end our our products
will become more competitive on the
European market the range of products
for duty-free Import and Export is
increasing the waiting time at the
borders is shortened Transportation
costs are reduced and smooth movement of
services in the area of e-commerce is
enabled the qualifications of
professionals are recognized and the
quality of Education increases we have
already signed agreements within the
framework of the Brewing process which
covered seven professions but this will
only deep deepen and expand and New
Opportunities and access to education
under European conditions and standards
will be opened costs for non-cash Border
crossborder payments are
reduced road traffic is being
liberalized additional opportunities for
participation in the energy
transformation processes of Europe are
opening up we aspire to be an energy
independent country with with immense
potential for investment in renewable
energy we have already set the country
on that b and we are working to become
the green energy Hub of Europe now we
will have the opportunity to be active
actors in the energy transition of
Europe having in mind that we are
already part of the European energy
Community we will be able to tr truly
rely on our European friends in terms of
energy but also together with all other
EU countries to decide on the energy
future of Europe because we are part of
it and let us not forget roaming prices
are reduced for calls and messages that
will be the following step not only for
data transfer as it was so
far the countries from the Western Balan
already use that benefit among ourselves
and it is already clear how important it
is for the companies and the citizens
all these benefits go hand inand with
the reform processes that are ahead of
us for which we have the political will
and knowledge and capacity to fulfill
them we take concrete actions open doors
to
us
based on
Merit this is done by our experts
employed in our Ministries and we're
commended for it by the European
commission we undertook concrete actions
we opened the doors based on Merit and
we step forward on the European
integration path in the same way we also
plan to work with the aim of Maximum
utilization of the funds that will be
available through this plan2 billion EUR
are planned in Grants that will attract
4 billion
in loans for strategic projects that
will improve the life of the citizens
and the operation of the companies but
also the infrastructure for connectivity
between the Western Balkan it is an
indisputable fact that European
Integrations are particularly important
for the economic development of the
country because they provide access to
funds from our independence until today
the financial support of the EU is
estimated at over 3.3 billion euros
grants and microf financial support
currently there are several current
lines of funds here I must also mention
the almost complete
utilization of eart 2 which increased
the package for eart 3 to 97 million EUR
which our citizens and our
companies have been utilizing and we are
the first one in doing so we should also
mention the funds planned through the
EPA 3 instrument but also funds
available to us through the investment
fund for the Western Balkans in which 9
billion EUR are projected for
Investments until
2027 which should attract additional 20
billion EUR for favorable loans from the
international financial institutions
here I mean the large infrastructural
projects for Railway connectivity of the
corridors with the neighboring countries
the gas connectivity with Greece to the
new LNG Terminals and other
infrastructural
projects these funds as I said are
intended for a large infrastructural
project and they are a real stake in our
future as well as the
region this confirms that our European
integration as a government brings
results both for the country for the
companies and the citizens due to the
stable security environment after NATO
membership investors already recognize
our country as a good destination
foreign direct investments in 2022
amounted to almost
754 million double more more than
2016 investments in
tadz as as of 2023 amount to2 billion
EUR compared to6 million EUR in
2016 this is an indication that the
European way is the right way with EU
membership the results will be even
better this is also shown by the
analysis for the countries but also the
experiences of the countries before and
after joining the EU in terms of FDI
they increased by 28% on average in the
first 5 years of the membership in the
union the Czech Republic out of 5.5
billion today has
about 8 billion dollar in Euros in
Investments out of five 5.4 billion
Romania has 7 billion in foreign FD
annually Malta from 400 million a year
when it was not a member of the EU 5
years after the membership has 21
billion EUR in foreign d direct
Investments at the same time the
analysis show that the funds from the
European funds are 11 times larger for a
member State than the funds available
for the candidate countries this is
exactly why I say that the growth plan
comes at the right moment and it brings
above all an opportunity for economic
development and ultimately for a better
standard of living of the citizens other
politicians talked about this in our
country even former
presidents and of course it is something
good but now we are speaking of concrete
realization and start of activities in
that regard the European future the
European way of life is the desire of
the citizens this is as true today as it
was in
1991 and in
2016 after more than a decade of
stagnation and active and systematic
regression of all Democratic processes
that brought the country to the status
of a captive state today only six years
later we are a NATO member state with
negotiations with the EU
started and only a year and a half ago
great deal of the citizens and I would
say even member states of the EU
wondered whether North Macedonia can
start negotiations and whether it can
have a negotiation framework we showed
that yes it can be done and after 17
years North Macedonia can start
negotiations with the EU we have a
government that is trans arent and
accountable and it enabled the country
to be in the 38th Place in terms of
media freedom and freedom of expression
compared to the 118th Place in
2016 a country in which social
justice is a basic principle that works
and which results in a high in a higher
minimum 100% higher minimum wage 40%
higher pensions in just a few years an
average salary that is already over
€600 something that until a few years
ago was practically Unthinkable of
course we have a we have still a lot of
work to do we are aware of that but I
often say with demanding work there is
no goal that cannot be reached I believe
that this country and our citizens can
do much much more and better that they
will do everything for the European
future for the European future of
today's and future generations and that
is why I am confident that the EU
members Ship by
2030 is an ambitious but attainable goal
North Macedonia needs integration not
isolation as we've seen in the past the
road to the EU is not easy but it must
be taken because at the end of that road
is the big prize and that is
full-fledged membership into the EU
membership in a union of the most
developed richest countries with
economic Prosperity Social justce
Justice and Rule of democracy and law
our citizens the future Generations will
live in the EU proud to be macedonians
with their heads head held high with
Macedonian language with Macedonian
identity but what is most important
richer and with better standard than
what they have now thank you I would
like to thank the president of the
European commission once again I would
like to thank the Euro Ambassador gear
who is
always here to help the countries who
represents the European Union in a
dignified way and to the whole team from
the directorates of the European
commission who work daily with our
Ministries thank you thank you prime
minister now I invite the president of
the European commission fan to take the
floor thank you very much prime minister
dear dimita it's always a pleasure to be
here in Scopia and to to visit this
wonderful country and I'm here basically
today to tell you and the citizens of
North
Macedonia that you are on a good track
to join the European
Union I'm very much looking forward to
welcoming you you prime minister have
described the Improvement and the steps
forward um over the last years so um I
must say this is amazing to see the pro
ress that North Macedonia has done and
the
determination um to move forward in the
right direction is also uh
impressive we know that the European
Union has also a long history of
accession so it was not always a union
of 27 but we had one step after the next
of enlargement and it was always a
history of respect for each other and
for every
nation and the respect for the diversity
we
represent and therefore one day I'm
absolutely convinced that we will
Welcome North
Macedonia with its unique
identity and its own
language today we do have already 24
different languages in the European
Union and one day we will count
Macedonian among
them we had very good talks today thank
you very much and thank you very much
for the members of uh the government
that were also there at these talks
North Macedonia has already come such a
long way and you described it with many
impressive
figures so my wish is that you should
absolutely keep going the screening
process is indeed progressing smoothly
thank you very much for the excellent
work you've done the negoti ation teams
are doing a fantastic job also to this
part of the teams we aim to open
negotiations on the fundamentals cluster
still this
year and I know we can do
it I'm aware of course of the ongoing
work on amending your
Constitution the first steps have been
taken in your Parliament and that's good
news now I hope all parties will seize
this opportunity to move
forward because there is a true momentum
now all over the European Union and
those countries who want to join the
European Union for the enlargement
process so it's important to seize that
moment I know how these processes can be
challenging of course and I'm sure you
will live up to your reputation as a
successful multiethnic
Society you already body what is the
motto of the European Union it is united
in
diversity and this is actually also why
scopion has been awarded the prestigious
title of European capital of culture
2028 congratulations to
that my second message is we need to
bring our economies
closer and that's what we have already
been doing if we look back we have our
30 billion Euro investment plan for the
Western Balkans it's delivering fast for
example with the oslom and Bola solar
power
plants we are investing heavily in
renewable energy and this is good
because it gives us energy Independence
together and the bansy wind Park sun and
wind very important resources you have
them for renewable
energy of course you're right you
mentioned last year we went through an
severe energy
crisis but we stood together and we have
moved mountains we supported you with 80
million euros to cushion the impact of
high energy prices on households and
businesses we worked hard together to
secure um the energy that was needed
throughout the winter and we were
successful prices has have come down we
are still working on lowering them
further those have been testing times
but important is we overcame them
together and this was the fact in the
past but we also discussed energy today
so also for the future whatever the
challenge is in energy let's face them
together and let's overcome them
together we are ready to start
dispersing the 100 million euro in
microf financial assistance that we
announced but as I I said we need to do
more we need to bring our economies
closer if you look at the figures very
successful development but your economy
is at 42% of average income in the
European Union so what we aim to do
together is to double your
economy within the next decade and this
is the reason why we present the new
growth plan for the Western Balkans you
have described it indeed there are more
or less four important steps the first
is we give your companies access to key
parts of the European single Market we
basically open the doors to the European
single Market in seven different
important
sectors the second pillar is um we ask
you also to open your common regional
market in the western Balkans for your
neighbors and to complete complete this
common regional market because the
potential of the common regional market
in the western Balkans is huge the
common regional market could if we
complete it increase the GDP of the
western Balkans by 10% so it's a huge
opportunity to move
forward now the third pillar is if we
want to open the doors for the single
market and complete the common regional
market of the western Balkans this needs
positive reforms for example for the
business
environment and uh reforms for North
Macedonia could for example include an
efficient public
administration sound public finances an
improved business environment and it is
crucial as well to carry on with the
reforms for the independence of the
Judiciary and to fight
corruption these are all reforms to be
done to have a Level Playing Field with
the European single market and the the
Western Balkan common regional market as
reforms are never easy these reforms and
that's the fourth pillar will come with
investment and indeed we've proposed a 6
billion package for our Western Balkan
Partners so it's reform and investment
why are we proposing this because we
made a very good experience with this
principle in the European
Union um we have an investment plan for
our members that is called Next
Generation EU we put it in place after
the pandemic and it works the same way
reforms and investment and it is working
excellently so we thought why not open
this principle also for our friends in
the western
Balkans the growth plan will boost your
economy most importantly it will create
good jobs and it will support you of
course in parallel in your path towards
the European
Union I believe it is a right offer at
the right
time the plan has the potential to
double the size of your economy in a
decade that is the goal and it will play
an important role on your path towards
the European
Union you have consistently shown an
amazing dedication on this path towards
the European Union for example with your
alignment with the eu's response to
Russia's brutal war of aggression in
Ukraine I also want to commend you for
the great job you're doing as chairman
of the
occe so you have shown time and again
that you are a very reliable partner and
I thank you for
that thank you very
much thank you now we will hear the
questions from the media TMA
TV good afternoon Tamar garosa from TMA
TV
for Madam
fan president
fan does the the European commission
already looks at the FR German proposal
for reforms of the EU and whether
2030 since we will have the European
elections is an attainable goal for such
deep reforms of the Union having in mind
that the EU member states cannot
harmonize on the way it should be done
is 2030 attainable goal for the EU as it
is for the Western Balan countries to
complete their
obligations um things really changed for
the better because what we see now is a
true momentum in the process for
enlargement we want the Western Balkans
to join the European Union and for that
you have to to get ready and we have to
get ready indeed and it is very good
that now concrete discussion have
started within the European Union what
do we have to do to be ready what are
the questions that are open what are the
answers that we have to give this was
not the case in uh the last mandate for
example so something substantially
changed in this mandate it's getting
concrete and therefore my plea and
encouragement
also to move forward in the different
countries of the western Balkans because
this is the window of opportunity that
is now open and again this um process is
not
rigid it is merits based so um nobody
has to wait for a certain date you can
be faster the better the reform process
is the faster there is the possibility
for accession and this is very important
so there is a window of opportunity open
let's cease together this
moment now we will continue con
pet for the Prime Minister
kovachi do you expect that Macedonia
will meet the informal deadline for
Constitutional Amendments by December
and a comment of the president of the
European European commission what if
this does not happen
I've said on several occasions that I'm
a person who believes in a in
accomplishing the goals we have um a
chance to provide European future for
the country by making the necessary
decisions in the assembly and I hope
that those who in the history have shown
that they're opposing to the euro
Atlantic Integrations of the country
will finally for the first time in their
political existence
that they are in favor of European
future for the country why am I saying
this now because as the president said
now this is an open window of
opportunities for accession to the EU
because if a few years ago this topic
was
not discussed was not part of a broad
consensus of the member states now at
this moment all member states
are saying that there should be
enlargement and if you look at the map
of Europe in practice this mean
unification of Europe because the
Western Balkans on all its borders have
EU member states as neighbors we have
50% harmonization of the EU
legislation we have institutions that
are fully harmonized with the European
Union our economic system is on the
level of performances that enable micro
financial support of the EU and if it
was not so we would not have discussed
this now and that is why I believe that
everyone should be accountable should be
responsible before the future
Generations we should not calculate on
these matters we should not gain
political
rating we should not play with the
emotions of the citizens because it will
only mean repetition of the bad movie
we've seen for 11 years in the country
when we had regress of multiethnic
relations in North Macedonia at that
time
Macedonia regression in the relations
with the neighbors and when we did not
move for a single millimeter in NATO
integration and EU
integration we did not have any progress
at that time and that is why I say that
the bad experiences from the history
should not be repeated I will continue
with the partners from the Coalition
with the leaders in the coalition to
work to make the dream for European
Macedonia True by
20130 North Macedonia is a sovereign
country that makes its own choices so
the choice is on you and therefore I
deeply hope that all parties will seize
that moment and support the
Constitutional
changes because it is your future it is
your choice and all parties have a
responsibility for the future of North
Macedonia we want North Macedonia as
member of the European Union um and I
hope that therefore the move forward is
a good one supported by a broad
majority
s good afternoon Karina ncoa s TV
question for president fonder Wayan you
mentioned the
Constitutional changes on to occasions
in line of the negotiations and today
you do not have a meeting with the
leader ofan mitosi who is a key player
in this
process why is this so and additionally
in that regard he has expectations for
your meeting he said unconditional
negotiation
from the European Union taking into
consideration that the country and the
citizens have been making concessions
serious concessions in the name of Eur
Integra integration and including
several constitutional changes is it
possible to have unconditional
negotiations and for the uh for the
Constitutional changes to happen in
future and
when so um the constitutional changes
are a necessary step on the path of
accession to the European Union um and
it is amazing again what North Macedonia
has already achieved therefore um I very
much wish that North Macedonia is moving
forward as it did with determination
with passion and with big success um on
the accession path it is absolutely
usual that wherever I am I meet the head
of state and government depending on how
the Constitution is um so this is the
case in my Western Balkan uh trip here
but this is a case in every trip whether
it's abroad or for example also in the
European Union When I visit member
states uh there is the rule that I meet
with the head of state or
government and the West question
tv21
Zakir question for the prime Minister
prime minister
regarding
Thea resolution for Urgent truce in
Israel and Gaza our country voted as
voted uh abstained was uh did the
Ambassador fosi consulted the government
did he explain your decision and is the
government on that line does this mean
that North Macedonia does not want to
have peaceful life for the civilians in
Gaza North Macedonia
supports the humanitarian aspect of the
Jordan
resolution and respecting respect for
the law of the humanit respect for the
humanitarian law and
necessary access to electricity water
and medicines on the other hand
a great weakness of this resolution is
the not mentioning of the terrorist act
from Hamas on October the 7th which we
condemned most Gravely as well as the
right of Israel to defend itself and
that is why we voted in favor of the
Canadian Amendment of the
resolution the decision was not an easy
one we decided to vote abstained because
the resolution on one hand addresses the
humanitarian issues and we agree with
that part and we support that part but
the lack of mentioning what Hamas did on
October the 7th does not leave space for
another approach in terms of voting in
any case activities should continue of
the International Community for
providing long-term peace and stability
in the Middle East at the same time I
invite you to look at the
voting about the final resolution and
the Canadian
amendment that was submitted for the
resolution to be complete but it was not
accepted before the final voting on the
resolution and that is why great deal of
countries did what our country did
ambassador fosi of
course consulted the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs and the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs is part of the Macedonian
government and yes this is our view and
I see it clearly thank you now this is
the end of the press conference thank
you for your
[Music]
attention